[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public votre
rendez-vous de débat et de reportage en
étant centre pour 90 minutes comme tous
les soirs du lundi au jeudi 18h et 22h
sur public Sénart on prend le temps de
thèmes pour analyser ces thèmes grâce à
nos experts données du sens à
l'actualité vous le savez c'est notre
light motif et voici le sommaire de ce
24 mai plusieurs raids de drones ont
visé la région russe de Belgorod cette
nuit quel est le sens de ces attaques
ukrainiennes et saint leur ou le début
de la contre-offensive pourquoi les
avions de chasse joueront un rôle
crucial dans les prochaines semaines on
répond à toutes ces questions et on
décode aussi le soutien diplomatique de
la Chine réaffirmé aujourd'hui ce sera
juste après ces titres et puis dans
notre second débat vous le savez
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour on monte à bord des avions du futur
sont-ils électriques
un avion électrique de gros avantage
c'est que le coût d'exploitation est
très faible on a que le coût
d'électricité on parle de 2 à 3 euros
par heure de vol donc c'est très faible
donc ça veut dire qu'on peut faire des
rotations tout le temps on peut imaginer
un avion qui vole en permanence toute la
journée comme un bus
avec l'électrique ou l'hydrogène ou plus
sûrement les biocarburants le secteur
aérien affiche des objectifs ambitieux
de décarbonation mais l'avion propre
est-il possible ne faut-il pas plutôt
relancer à l'avion ici oui pour quelle
distance ne ratez pas la confrontation
de nos invités dans trois quarts d'heure
mais d'abord les dernières informations
sur cette incursion armée sur le
territoire russe avec Nadia alors
suite au récentes intrusions de
plusieurs groupes armés dans son pays la
Russie a décidé de mettre en place un
plan antiterroriste dans la région de
Belgorod
au moins 9 localités ont été évacuées
dans la région avec un contrôle strict
des déplacements et des
télécommunications objectifs ratissez
selon Moscou et mettre un terme aux
incursions d'opposants fréquentes au
cours de ces dernières semaines au moins
deux groupes se seraient en effet
introduits dans l'eau blast russe depuis
l'Ukraine selon le Kremlin ce sont des
nationalistes ukrainiens en aucun cas
des insurgés russes et pourtant
il est venu le temps de mettre fin à la
dictature du Kremlin merci beaucoup à
tous ceux qui nous soutiennent votre
soutien et ce qui nous rappelle chaque
jour notre objectif final notre objectif
final sur la Place Rouge
et n'ayez pas peur
parce que nous revenons à la maison
la Russie sera libre
selon le ministère de la Défense les
trappes Russes se sont encore poursuivis
la nuit dernière ses intrusions
d'opposants confortent dans tous les cas
la position de Moscou il faut maintenir
les pour les empêcher
nous continuerons de répondre rapidement
et de manière extrêmement ferme à de
telles actions
le reste des nationalistes ont été
repoussés sur le territoire de l'Ukraine
où ils ont continué à être vaincu
jusqu'à leur élimination totale plus de
70 terroristes Ukrainiens ainsi que des
véhicules et des véhicules blindés ont
été détruits le bilan est un vérifiable
mais la situation montre que les
frontières russes ne sont pas
infranchissables alors que Kiev se
prépare à lancer une offensive pour
récupérer ses territoires occupés
l'Ukraine d'ailleurs ni être impliquée
dans l'intrusion de ces groupes mais le
ministère de la Défense il voit une
crise interne à la Russie beaucoup
d'informations à commenter tout de suite
dans ce débat avec Jérôme clache bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes enseignants en
prospective et stratégie à Sciences Po
Paris et auteur de ce livre la
prospective stratégique qui paraît
aujourd'hui je crois aux éditions
Hermann Sylvie Berman bonsoir bienvenue
à vous ancien ambassadrice de France en
Chine et en Russie et auteur de ce livre
madame l'ambassadeur paru aux éditions
Tallandier j'accue également Lucas Aubin
bonsoir et bienvenue directeur de
recherche à l'IR des spécialistes de la
géopolitique de la Russie d'ailleurs
c'est le titre de votre livre
géopolitique de la Russie qui est paru
aux éditions de La Découverte Mathieu
croissanto bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à
vous vous êtes toujours éditorialiste
politique et c'est toujours un bonheur
de vous avoir sur ce plateau je commence
avec en rebondit sur le le sujet
évidemment qu'on vient de voir cette
incursion armée à Belgrade Jérôme
Claisse les Russes affirment que des
attaques de drones ont eu lieu encore
cette nuit dans la région ça veut dire
qu'elle est pas terminée alors on prend
toujours avec des pincettes tout
information en temps de guerre mais
comment vous l'analysez ce qui se passe
là-bas s'il faut remettre en perspective
il faut voir que c'est la loi du genre
en fait qui est des plusieurs niveaux de
d'action il peut y avoir des actions
clandestine et l'idée pour la Russie
c'est évidemment de faire passer une
résistance pour des actes terroristes et
ça c'est la loi du genre depuis que la
guerre est guerre après est-ce qu'il y a
un lien avec l'Ukraine l'Ukraine le
démon ça aussi c'est la loi du genre les
actions clandestine il faut les mener
c'est un niveau peu revendicable et
souvent pas revendiqué mais qui est tout
à fait nécessaire voilà donc après
chacun se fera une idée en général les
services ne confirment ni l'infirme leur
action réelle ou supposée c'est un petit
peu la c'est un petit peu les termes
employés voilà la situation se poursuit
ça pour ce qui est de la situation
tactique je ne peux pas en dire plus et
je ne sais pas exactement ce qu'il en
est là il faudrait du renseignement
carte à l'appui récent et récent et
carte à l'appui ça c'est le rôle des
états majors de l'établir mais en tout
cas pour la remise en perspective voilà
ce qu'on peut dire avec un point
particulier aussi c'est on a beaucoup
espéré on a beaucoup glosé aussi sur un
possible effondrement de l'Intérieur
pardon de la Russie
à cet égard il faut voir quand même que
il y a une certaine solidité dans
l'adhésion même si elle est molle une
certaine solidité de l'adhésion du
peuple russe même si il y a eu des
remarques des critiques parfois acerbes
sur les modalités de cette fameuse
opération spéciale elle est rarement
discutée dans son bien fondé parce que
je parle ce contrôle de Madame berckman
il y a quand même un narratif qui a la
vie dure il y a cette soucis de
restaurer la Grande Russie il y a quand
même l'idée que l'expansion de l'OTAN
aurait été à tort ou à raison à
l'origine de cette agression russe et il
y a quand même aussi une sorte de
résignation qui fait que il y a peu de
chances de penser que ces insurgés
constitueraient le début d'un
effondrement de l'intérieur c'est ça qui
est important et c'est ça qui est
intéressant effectivement Sylvie Berman
là on vous vous employez le terme
résistance évidemment côté rue on parle
de de terrorisme mais mais il faut avoir
en tête quand même des décennies de
alors je sais pas quel terme employé
d'informations des informations de
lavage de cerveau enfin de de
conditionnement de manipulation russe
face à des informations comme celle-là
oui tout à fait de toute façon
l'information est maintenant
pratiquement inaccessible pour la
majorité des Russes qui sont condamnés à
regarder la télévision d'État qui est
une télévision de propagande et en
réalité il y a le narratif que vous
venez d'évoquer mais il y a surtout le
fait qu'aujourd'hui les autorités russes
et cela depuis quelques mois explique
que en fait c'est l'OTAN qui attaque la
Russie et ils disent d'ailleurs on sait
aujourd'hui contre qui on se bat
l'Ukraine est à peine évoquée d'avoir
parce que c'est un peu humiliant pour la
Russie
d'échouer des choix en Ukraine et ça
c'est un narratif effectivement qui
porte en particulier dans les
générations les plus âgées alors c'est
de groupes quand même qui se sont alliés
c'est un petit peu étrange parce que
vous avez effectivement un groupe qui se
dit bon de résistance bon liberté de de
la Russie et puis vous avez un autre
groupe qui a un groupe de légionnaires
dont le but c'est de
restaurer alors la masculinité l'héroïne
et puis la Fraternité Blanche c'est à
dire que se véritablement un groupe
suprématie mais qui reproche à la Russie
d'être multiculturelle donc comme
résistant supposée représentés la
démocratie c'est un petit peu
problématique et je pense que
l'Ukraine revendique peut-être pas de
lien avec avec ces groupes là ou l'un de
ces groupes tout à fait c'est à la fois
parce qu'elle ne revendique pas de lien
avec ce groupe et aussi parce que elle
ne revendique pas les attaques en
territoire russe Lucas Aubin c'est deux
groupes on en avait déjà entendu parler
il y avait déjà eu des actions menées
par voilà c'est c'est résistant russe je
sais pas quel terme à loyer on savait à
peu près depuis le début du conflit il y
avait certains russes effectivement qui
avaient décidé de retourner leurs veste
entre guillemets pour le moment il n'y
avait pas eu d'action concrètes qui
avaient été menée sur le territoire de
la fédération de Russie néanmoins on
sait que depuis en tout cas pas
officiellement on sait que depuis par
contre quelques semaines la
multiplication des attaques de drone par
exemple ou des attaques d'obus sur des
zones stratégiques en Russie se
multiplient et à partir de là on peut
soit se poser la question on peut se
poser la question de d'où viennent ces
attaques est-ce que ce sont les forces
ukrainiennes qui attaquent directement
le territoire de la fédération de Russie
sachant que les États-Unis ont donné on
dit aux autorités ukrainiennes que si
jamais elle devait attaquer le
territoire de la Russie alors elle
n'aurait plus d'aide potentielle
américaine donc il y a forcément un
enjeu de ce côté là et donc de fait
est-ce que finalement ce sont réellement
des Russes qui attaquent le territoire
russe pour le moment c'est difficile
évidemment de le dire j'aimerais
rebondir sur ce que vous avez dit juste
avant en Russie effectivement depuis une
vingtaine d'années il y a une un espace
informationnel disons qui est assez
contrôlé effectivement par l'État
central mais on a vu par exemple que
depuis le 24 février les applications de
téléphone les plus téléchargées étaient
des GPN à savoir des logiciels qui
permettent de tourner on va dire
contourner cette espèce informationnelle
et obtenir des informations venues de
l'extérieur alors ça ne constitue pas
évidemment la majorité de la population
russe ou un sans faut mais il existe
quand même une partie de cette
population qui cherche à contourner
cette propagande finalement alors je
vais rester avec vous sur sur cette
guerre informationnelle je vous propose
d'abord dans ce cadre là d'entendre une
réaction officielle russe suite à ces
attaques à Belgorod celle du
porte-parole du mystère de la défense
lors de l'opération antiterroriste à
l'aide de frappes de l'aviation et de
l'artillerie et de l'action des unités
de défense des frontières du district
militaire de l'Ouest et formation
nationalistes ukrainienne ont été
bloquées et écrasées le reste des
nationalistes ont été repoussés sur le
territoire de l'Ukraine où les frappes
se sont poursuivies jusqu'à leur
élimination totale plus de 70
terroristes Ukrainiens quatre véhicules
blindés de combat et 5 camionnettes ont
été détruits alors je vous laisse
continuer votre propos peut-être côté
pouvoir russe est-ce que la lumière
Poutine qui donnait quand même le
sentiment de maîtriser la la
communication autour de cette guerre la
maîtrise un peu moins qu'avant d'après
vous alors il y a des signaux qui
montrent que effectivement c'est un peu
plus branlant qu'avant ça c'est vrai on
n'est pas sur non plus des signaux
extrêmement importants dans le sens où
il y a gagné prigogi effectivement le
chef de la mise Wagner qui parle de plus
en plus sur les réseaux sociaux qui
s'expriment contre l'état-major russe
directement c'est à dire
par exemple le ministre de la Défense
russe et il aurait potentiellement parlé
de Vladimir Poutine en parlant de
grands-pères alors on en a pas la
certitude effectivement mais le message
semblait quand même assez clair donc
Yves gaming prigogne devient de plus en
plus puissant c'est un peu
suit un peu ses propres intérêts en ce
moment et étant donné qu'il est
officiellement crit qu'il très critique
à l'égard du régime russe alors que ce
n'était pas le cas avant on peut
imaginer qu'il respecte moins justement
cette verticale du pouvoir qui existait
jusqu'à présent ensuite il y a eu ces
deux attaques de drone sur le Kremlin il
faut se souvenir la veille du 9 mai
dernier en Russie qui sont évidemment
des attaques très importantes très
symboliques on avait pas vu ça mais au
plus fort de la guerre froide il faut
bien l'imaginer parce qu'il y avait un
soupçon de de manipulation à l'époque
enfin justement on est pas sûr
effectivement on n'est pas sûr mais quel
que soit les scénarios en fait dans tous
les cas c'est un aveu de faible est-ce
que ce soit les Ukrainiens qui a réussi
à attaquer directement le Kremlin que ce
soit les Russes qui eux-mêmes le Kremlin
pour je sais pas préparer une
contre-offensive ou alors que ce soit
une opposition russe en Russie dans tous
les cas c'est un aveu de faiblesse
finalement le Kremlin est censé être la
zone la plus protégée dans le Russie
quand même alors on parle de drone je
pense qu'on a réussi à caler une vidéo
très courte c'est l'une des informations
de cette fin d'après-midi de ce mercredi
les Russes qui
accusent l'Ukraine d'avoir attaqué un de
leurs bateaux voilà c'est très c'est
très rapide alors là ce qu'on voit
décrypter c'est ces images peut-être
Jérôme clache ce sont je parle de drone
ce sont des drones des bateaux sans
pilotes c'est ça en tout cas alors je
vais être précis images fournie par les
Russes déjà on va commencer par dire ça
qu'on n'a pas eu le temps de vérifier de
valider donc beaucoup beaucoup de
prudence mais elles sont quand même
intéressantes à analyser même si c'est
de la propagande
russe ce serait quoi ce serait une
attaque avec des des bateaux sans
pilotes contre un contre un bateau russe
dans ce qu'on appelle la zone économique
turque c'est quoi la zone les eaux
économiques Turcs la zone économique
exclusive c'est 200 nautiques donc un
peu moins de 400 km des côtes voilà dans
lequel on peut revendiquer une
exploitation économique des gens
territoriales c'est non voilà les
territorial qui sont beaucoup plus
restreintes qui sont là à 12 nautiques
des côtes c'est-à-dire 30 km voilà et
donc dans ces zones économiques
exclusives forcément il y a des intérêts
stratégiques et tout incursion dans
cette zone est susceptible de tension
voilà après commenter les images s'il
faut les commenter c'est plus sous
l'angle informationnel ce que vous dites
est fort possible s'agissant de de
j'allais dire de de véhicules de
véhicules pilotés à distance des
équivalents de drone naval c'est
possible mais ça reste à vérifier je ne
peux pas me prononcer là dessus
est-ce que c'est arrivé ou je peux me
prononcer c'est l'écran de fumée parce
que c'est véritablement à l'image de
cette communication et de cette guerre
informationnelle que fait la Russie
c'est le cas aussi sur le ou à 10 ans un
nuage radioactif de kelinsky soit disant
un nuage radioactif de d'uranium
appauvri bon techniquement c'est
totalement impossible uranium appauvri
est trop dense pour faire un nuage en
plus c'est pas de la matière physique
etc où je vais en venir c'est que en
matière de guerre d'informationnelle que
ce soit vrai ou faux ça a pas grande
importance ce qui compte c'est pas
tellement qui maîtrise ou qui est une
perte de maîtrise c'est l'effet de
saturation c'est de saturer l'ennemi
toujours comme en artillerie le tir
d’altyrie c'est ça viser juste pour
l'artillerie c'est pas très utile il
faut saturer là c'est exactement la même
chose et donc à cet égard on peut quand
même reconnaître que c'est quand même
assez efficace et ce qu'en face notre
guerre informationnelle celle de
l'Ukraine et compétitive celle de
voldemirzeninski naturellement c'est
comme ça que l'aide internationale a été
levée elle est tout à fait assymétrique
dans un cas il y a assez peu de jeux
avec la vérité même s'il y a toujours
une invité à appréhender les choses et
puis aller présenter de façon positive
dans l'autre la désinformation c'est la
norme Wagner la désinformation en
Afrique c'est la norme l'intoxication
c'est la norme la fake news c'est la
norme l'écran de fumée là c'est la norme
qu'est-ce que vous voulez analyser un
écran de fumée pareil encore une fois je
reviens sur la radioactivité pourquoi
parce qu'on sait que dans l'imaginaire
collectif c'est tout de suite l'escalade
vers le nucléaire aujourd'hui on parle
d'une possible contrefensive c'est la
façon déjà de contrer la
contre-offensive en disant souvenez-vous
du cadenas nucléaire si vous allez trop
loin c'est ce qui peut se produire peu
importe que la matière soit fissile ou
pas peu importe que l'uranium appauvri
soit crédible dans le rôle d'une
explosion nucléaire ce n'est pas le
sujet parce que ça va très vite et que
c'est la saturation qui compte et ça
qu'on voit l'image et puis Sylvie verman
dans dans encore une fois avec beaucoup
de prudence cette l'information qui est
aussi importante c'est la zone
économique exclusive turque quoi c'est à
dire que
diplomatiquement ça n'est pas neutre
évidemment de de dire ça et ça aura
peut-être des conséquences oui bien sûr
et ça permet
plus de dénoncer une fois de plus
l'accord intervenu sur sur les céréales
puisque une des conditions c'est que les
Ukrainiens ne puissent pas attaquer les
bâtons russes donc je ne sais pas de
quel bateau il s'agit mais d'une
certaine manière peu importe
en ce qui concerne effectivement la
saturation de l'information je pense que
on a l'illusion d'avoir des images sur
cette guerre d'avoir des informations
parce que on en a effectivement beaucoup
mais elles sont complètement distillées
soit par la Russie soit par l'Ukraine et
en réalité on n'a pas de d'informations
neutrou fiables sur rien en réalité le
nombre de victimes d'un côté comme de
l'autre on l'ignore totalement
le nombre de missiles utilisés ou qu'il
reste encore on ne sait pas non plus
l'état de préparation des
Ukrainiens pour la contre-offensive qui
est sans cesse reportée on n'a pas d'
relation non plus alors qu'on a le
sentiment d'en avoir beaucoup parce
qu'on voit beaucoup d'images que qu'on
nous montre alors on va parler de cette
contre-offensive évidemment et je
propose à Jonathan du priez de nous
rejoindre tout de suite parce qu'on va
parler de l'importance des des avions de
combat bonsoir Jonathan l'Ukraine qui
aurait réclame depuis des mois à ses
alliés de l'OTAN justement pour réussir
cette contre-offensive ça commence à
porter ses fruits et oui lobbying
intense de Volodia Mark Zelensky comment
ça à marcher sur les Occidentaux même si
à ce stade on n'a pas vraiment de date
de livraison de ces avions mais on sent
qu'il y a une sorte de verrou
occidentale qui qui commence à sauter à
Hiroshima il y a trois jours le
président des États-Unis l'a levé en
fait son veto auprès des alliés de Kiev
sur la livraison d'avions américains F16
à l'armée ukrainienne et parce que c'est
des avions ont fabrication
américaine donc il faut que les Alliés
soient autorisés par les États-Unis
avant de les donner à l'Ukraine donc vol
le 10 mars zenzki il a salué une
décision historique parce parce que
c'est vrai que les américains ils ont
opéré une sorte de virage à 180 degrés
par rapport à leur position via encore
trois mois où il refusait de livrer ses
chasseurs pour limiter une escalade avec
Moscou alors on peut se demander aussi
pourquoi le F16 pourquoi ce modèle
spécifiquement vous allez voir
d'ailleurs s'afficher à l'antenne et
bien sans forcément être une solution
miracle c'est un aéronef qui est assez
connu pour sa polyvalence qui a été
maintes fois testé approuvé sur toutes
les zones de conflits du monde mais
surtout c'est le chasseur on va dire le
plus standard du monde il en a 4500
exemplaires en circulation et il y a
déjà pas mal de pays un pays bas
Grande-Bretagne Danemark Pologne qui
sont déjà candidats pour en livrer
l'Ukraine et la France que que peut-elle
apporter la France et bien alors la
France déjà elle se range derrière le
derrière ses alliés elle suit évidemment
elle soutient cette décision et la
France surtout pourrait former des
pilotes
Ukrainiens mais alors on peut aussi se
dire que les Françaises en vérité elle
est un petit peu limitée on est un peu à
la remorque de nos alliés parce qu'on
utilise pas de 16 américains on pourrait
donc apporter une formation théorique au
sol à deux jeunes pilotes mais pas
davantage et des formations qui seraient
très longue sur trois ou quatre ans
peut-être en tout cas pour le président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
ici au Sénat l'Ukraine et bien elle a
surtout besoin de moyens terrestres
écoutez ce qu'il disait Christian
Courmont d'abord on a pas de F16 et ce
dont a besoin lui craint des
renseignements que nous avons c'est
effectivement des moyens terrestres et
là les décisions de renforcer par les
AMX 10 qui sont des moyens blindés très
rapides et très efficaces répondent déjà
aux attentes de l'Ukraine alors on peut
aussi se demander Jonathan pourquoi la
France n'en trouve pas la porte à une
livraison de Rafale et oui c'est vrai
puisque on en fabrique des rafales et
malgré la visite du président zellenski
à Paris on peut penser qu'il y a eu
aussi ça au menu des discussions avec
Emmanuel Macron et ben rien ne semble
bouger du côté de l'Elysée Emmanuel
Macron en février dernier il avait jugé
je cite qu'il y avait plusieurs gens et
plus utile pour les Ukrainiens donc
notamment ces fameux moyens terrestres
dont on vient de parler Christian
Campbon et pour ce qui est des rafales
et bien beaucoup de problèmes aussi se
posent pour les livrer à d'éventuelles
combattants Ukrainiens peu d'armée dans
le monde utilise notre technologie et
hors de question de les prélever sur
notre flotte la France elle est on peut
le dire à l'os avec 185 chasseurs au
total donc 96 rafales et bien il y en a
pas un trop pour assurer l'émission
confiées aux ailes françaises
entraînement et missions extérieures
comprises merci Jonathan reviendra
peut-être sur l'aspect français mais je
voudrais Jérôme clé je vous entends sur
l'importance de l'aviation il y a cette
contre-offensif effectivement dont on
parle depuis des semaines
l'importance de l'aviation dans cette
contrepensive alors c'est pas devant une
diplomate que je ne reviendrai pas sur
l'importance politique c'est-à-dire que
il faut savoir quel est l'état final
recherché état final recherché c'est
arrivé aussi fort que possible dans des
négociations
qui vont se faire vraisemblablement avec
un rôle prépondérant pour la Chine c'est
à dire vraisemblablement pas à
l'avantage de l'Ukraine donc il faut un
rapport de force sur le terrain qui soit
significatif
inversé si possible un fléchi à minima
mais inversé si possible de sorte qu'à
ce que l'Ukraine ne soit pas obligé de
faire des concessions territoriales trop
importantes c'est ça donc
il faut regarder le terrain par
conséquent quel est l'effet à produire
sur le plan militaire pour servir cet
état final politique et bien il faut
renverser le rapport de force comment
faire là il y a pas 36 solutions la
condition du succès qui est nécessaire
non suffisante c'est un rapport de force
aérien et la suite la conséquence de
tout ça c'est la trace au sol un rapport
de force et rester ça se fait dans cet
ordre là il y a eu plus de 30 opérations
extérieures menées ces 30 dernières
années essentiellement par les
États-Unis en cas de Bretagne ou pas en
coalition et c'est toujours le même
modèle qui fonctionne peu importe
l'objectif politique en l'occurrence
mais c'est ce modèle là qui fonctionne
s'il y a pas une campagne aérienne
puissante au départ un rapport de force
aérien puissant il ne peut rien avoir de
bon sur le plan terrestre le fait que
cette contre-offensif soit a priori
retardé naturellement parce que pour
avoir ce rapport de force aérien il faut
je reviens sur ce que disait votre
journaliste et son excellent son
excellent rapport sur la question il
faut être capable de mener d'avoir une
pratique d'être rompue à la pratique des
opérations aériennes c'est pas
uniquement mettre des avions en l'air
c'est faire du commandement et du
contrôle parce que l'armée aérienne est
très sensible j'allais dire à la
synchronisation au timing au fait Dieu
bien articuler les choses c'est vraiment
de la haute couture voilà donc le
commandement et le contrôle le ciblage
c'est à dire quoi frapper ou frapper
quand frapper dans la profondeur ça veut
dire quoi dans la profondeur ça veut
dire frapper des concentrations de force
dans le dos basse pourquoi pas en Crimée
c'est là qu'il faut frapper et articuler
effectivement la manœuvre aérienne et
les forces trop terrestres ensuite pour
pouvoir véritablement avancé ne pas
frapper ses propres trous bien frapper
les troupes adverses ça c'est la chose
c'est ça la planification c'est ça le
ciblage enfin faut être capable d'agir
en coalition parce que vous allez avoir
un afflux de F16 le cas échéant si ça se
fait on parle pour que ce soit
significatif d'une plusieurs dizaines de
SS c'est ça qu'il faut répéter même plus
sont formés aujourd'hui on en vient
ensuite à la formation en tant que tel
là c'est en fonction quelques mois ou
quelques années selon qu'il soit déjà
formé ou pas quoi qu'il en soit c'est
une opération sans regret parce que que
l'OTAN intègre l'Ukraine à terme ou pas
il faut il y a un rapprochement
irréversible de l'Ukraine de l'Occident
et donc former ces pilotes c'est de
toute façon à faire donc c'est pas une
perte de temps et quand vous arrivez à
réunir l'ensemble de ces couches là vous
pouvez mener des opérations aériennes
donc le commandement le contrôle le
ciblage la planification la formation la
logistique pour être capable de faire
décoller les avions des pistes
ukrainiennes sans doute faudra-t-il les
aménager et les rallonger un petit peu
etc et puis il est formé à ces missions
là les missions c'est l'émission de
défense aérienne pour avoir la
suprématie ou au moins la supériorité
locale que rien ne puisse arriver au
dessus des trous ukrainiennes et ensuite
la TAC au sol avec une synchronisation
encore une fois pour faire avancer leur
troupes donc forcément ça prend des mois
forcément ça prend beaucoup de temps et
c'est là où la question qui se pose
c'est celle de par rapport à cet état
finalement recherché politique si
l'objectif est les frontières de 91 il
va falloir dimensionner ça à la hausse
avec des dizaines d'avions F16 et
probablement même plus si on voulait
faire ça voilà si en revanche l'objectif
est plus celui annoncé par les
Américains c'est à dire résister plus
que d'amener à la victoire dans ce cas
là on peut arriver à quelque chose de
plus limité et l'effet de surprise doit
garder la primeur mais ça pourrait
arriver dans les mois qui suivent il
faut que ça arrive dans les mois qui
suivent Mathieu je vous posais une
question de de
tout ce temps que mes lucrètes se
préparait c'est aussi du temps à la
Russie pour se contre préparer le temps
ne joue pas en la faveur de l'Ukraine à
cet égard parce que la Russie a déjà
commencé elle s'accompagne d'attrition
elle a réinvesti dans une moindre mesure
mais la réinvesti la dimension aérienne
aérospatiale des octobre 2022 à la suite
de cet enlisement qui avait été
caractérisé par Carson fin septembre
début octobre voilà et donc cette
attrition même si l'Ukraine intercepte
grâce au Patriote grâce au crotale qui a
aussi qui a fourni la France un certain
nombre de missiles y compris le kingjal
et bien ça ne suffit pas parce que en
stratégie l'épée l'emporte toujours sur
le bouclier donc la l'Ukraine va se
faire poncer tout simplement éroder au
fil du temps donc effectivement le temps
joue contre elle mais en même temps on
ne peut pas s'y reprendre à plusieurs
fois c'est à dire qu'au moment où elle
lancera sa contre-offensive si elle
s'épuise faute d'avoir les moyens de
cette bien coordonnée ce sera raté donc
de deux mots faut choisir le moindre et
le plus important sans doute c'est aussi
la guerre cognitive c'est à dire de
faire croire à la contre-offensive alors
ça je sais pas le dire mais c'est
vraiment important c'est à dire que
l'idée je vous demandais de d'arrêter
voilà que tout le monde puisse parler
c'était passionnant donc j'ai pas voulu
vous vous interrompre plus tôt mais je
vous redonnerai la parole évidemment du
chaos bas oui il y a cette notion de
brouillard de guerre tiens par exemple
dont on parle souvent mais je voudrais
vous entendre sur le le le
l'armée russe que disait Mathieu on en
est où en nombre d'hommes en il y a
combien de de
nouveaux soldats qu'il a fallu former
qu'est-ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui de
l'état de l'armée alors c'est très
difficile d'avoir des chiffres sachant
que je ne suis pas spécialiste militaire
donc sur la question sur le terrain j'ai
des difficultés à répondre en revanche
on sait que par exemple la milice Wagner
donc contre les Paris vikeniprigognes
aurait parce que toujours la même chose
utiliser les conditionnel recruter entre
30 000 et 50 000 hommes dans les prisons
quand il a commencé à recruter donc à
l'automne dernier
on sait et selon ses dires donc
probablement peut-être pas mon rêve on
ne sait pas exactement mais en tout cas
que sur ces 50000 hommes il en aurait
déjà perdu à peu près 30 000 ce qui est
évidemment énorme donc ça montre bien
que sur le terrain à baroute en
l'occurrence donc qui était l'un des
l'un des nœuds de cette guerre récemment
encore il aurait donc perdu plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes
ensuite si on regarde sur le temps
disons moyens on voit que l'armée russe
a reculé depuis à peu près avril en
réalité 2022 déjà et n'a pas réussi
finalement à regagner un terrain
suffisamment significatif pour parler de
victoire et ce que ce qu'on voit
actuellement c'est justement ce conflit
informationnel qu'on a autour de barcoon
c'est à dire que on a effectivement
gagné brigandin qui dit avoir remporté
la bataille de Mahmoud et finalement en
face on a les Ukrainiens qui répondent
peut-être pas on ne sait pas exactement
et en fait est-ce que c'est réellement
si important que ça et en fait se pose
la question désormais de savoir si
l'armée ukrainienne n'aurait pas utilisé
barthmoud justement cette ville comme
une façon en fait de d'annuler en fait
les forces russes c'est de faire en
sorte que justement des centaines voire
des milliers d'hommes meurent meurent au
combat par contre le président
ukrainien on a en a parlé il y a
quelques jours c'était à l'occasion du
sommet du G7 qui se tenait en le disait
avec Jonathan tout à l'heure au Japon à
Hiroshima évidemment ville symbole je
propose d'écouter ce que disait volody
beerselenski lors de cette conférence de
presse à Hiroshima
honnêtement je peux dire que les photos
d'Hiroshima détruites me rappelle barmut
et d'autres villes dans ce genre il n'y
a absolument plus rien de vivant tous
les bâtiments sont détruits on ne sait
même plus où se trouve la rue où se
trouve un bâtiment il n'y a plus rien il
n'y a plus personne
Sylvie Berman je je reviens autour de la
question de
la stratégie française on va dire on a
entendu les arguments militaires donnés
par Jonathan du priez sur le fait de ne
pas livrer de rafale ou de pas vouloir
rentrer dans cette logique là est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres raisons des raisons
diplomatiques des raisons de
positionnement
stratégique politique de la France alors
moi je ne peux me référer que ce qui ce
qui a été dit effectivement à la fois
par le président puis là vous allez le
président également de la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense du
Sénat disant que la priorité ce ne sont
pas les avions alors vous êtes d'un avis
différent cela étant si on écoute les
experts qui disent qu'il faut des mois
ou des années il pourra pas y avoir
d'offensif qui avait été annoncé pour le
printemps or l'offensive aura
probablement lieu avant parce que et si
elle a été reportée c'est peut-être pour
des raisons effectivement logistiques
c'est pour d'autres raisons aussi c'est
que ils savent bien que il y a des
pressions y compris des Américains pour
qu'il y ait des négociations
effectivement ils savent aussi qu'ils
n'auront pas plusieurs chances donc si
effectivement cette offensive échoue et
qui ne sont pas en situation de
récupérer suffisamment de territoire
donc d'être en situation de supériorité
ça va être très difficile d'avoir une
deuxième
contrefensive majeure donc
bon voilà probablement la raison du
report successif de cette conforme
contre offensive annoncée à grand
renfort de publicité et un d'une
certaine manière du point de vue
français je pense que c'est un peu la
même ligne malgré tout que les
Américains parce que si les Américains
autorisent la livraison de F-16
eux-mêmes ne vont pas en livrer ils ont
posé des conditions depuis le début à la
fourniture d'armes à long porter
certaines visent pas le territoire russe
bon ce qui se passe à Belgorod ou
ailleurs c'est de c'est d'une autre
nature
et
donc le président
de la de la stratégie américaine ou des
annonces américaines même les Américains
je dirais les autorise la livraison de
F16 par d'autres pays qui en disposent
eux-mêmes ne livre pas de livre pas
d'avion donc c'est vrai qu'il y a une
certaine prudence dans ce domaine et
puis je pense comme ça a été expliqué
que de toute façon les rafales ont
d'autres
usages pour pour le moment et que ce
sont des appareils très sophistiqués et
que le fournir a des pilotes qui sont
certainement bons parce que les
Ukrainiens ont une bonne réputation dans
dans ce domaine mais malgré tout ils
n'ont pas l'habitude de voler sur ce
type de d'avions Mathieu pendant que
l'Ukraine prépare sa sa contre-offensive
la France elle discute du budget de ces
armées en ce moment évidemment
l'invasion russe a changé la donne oui
en tout cas en termes sonan est
trébuchant et ça mérite d'être souligné
la loi de programmation militaire dans
l'examen a commencé cette semaine
semaine à l'Assemblée prévoit de porter
le niveau des dépenses à 413 milliards
d'euros pour la période 2024 2030 la
précédente c'était 295 milliards pour
vous donner une idée c'est un effort
historique sur le montant entre 2017 et
2030 la dépense militaire annuelle aura
quasiment doublée c'est historique aussi
parce que l'exécutif a tenu parole et ça
aussi ça mérite d'être relevé parce que
c'est rare d'habitude on le sait on
annonce d'abord puis on Rogue après sous
la Cinquième République quand on croyait
encore à la fin de l'histoire mais
toutes les les coupes budgétaires
commençaient très très souvent par
l'armée et pourtant cette loi de
programmation militaire elle ne fait pas
pour autant l'unanimité pourquoi alors
le cercle conflit ukrainien a amené la
France à programmer une augmentation de
munitions par exemple ou de certains
matériels comme des systèmes de défense
solaire mais cette loi de programmation
militaire mais surtout l'accent en
termes de dépenses sur la modernisation
de notre force de dissuasion nucléaire
sur la construction d'un nouveau
porte-avions sur de nouveaux défis comme
l'espace comme le cyber et au risque
selon certains de déc la livraison
d'autres équipements comme des
blindéscorpions des rafales des frégates
dont les armées auraient pourtant bien
besoin et puis surtout pour beaucoup
d'experts la France n'a pas profité de
cette loi de programmation militaire
pour conduire une révolution ou même une
transformation de notre modèle militaire
nos armées faut comprendre qu'elles
veulent continuer en gros de pouvoir
tout faire de disposer des meilleurs
matériels si possible conçus par des
ingénieurs français mais à la hauteur de
ses moyens c'est à dire en version
miniature par rapport à l'armée
américaine le journal l'opinion par
exemple a calculé que en cas de conflit
de force intensité comme en Ukraine et
ben nos forces ne pourraient tenir
qu'une ligne de front de 70 à 80 km et
puis pas sur une très longue durée et à
77000 hommes qui sont vraiment
mobilisables donc voilà c'est pour ça
fait pas forcément l'unanimité et ça va
nourrir les débats au Parlement avant
une adoption définitive qui est prévue
pour le symbole si possible avant le 14
juillet évidemment et ça va nourrir
notre débat également
Jérôme clache est-ce que vous dites vous
aussi qu'il y a une occasion manquée de
revoir le modèle et fallait-il le faire
les mots ont leur importance est-ce que
c'est une LPM de transformation ou de
réparation sans doute plus une LPM de
réparation ce qui n'est déjà pas si mal
parce que
l'outil de défense a quand même été
érodé pendant plus de 20 ans et c'est
quand même la première fois qu'il y a
une hausse si significative avec quand
même une capacité à assurer ce qui est
quand même notre sanctuaire c'est-à-dire
la dissuasion nucléaire qui fait que si
les intérêts vitaux de la France étaient
menacés et bien nous aurions de quoi
dissuader tout adversaire d'y attenter
davantage
ça c'est la brique de base du modèle et
c'est extrêmement coûteux modernisé que
ce soit les sous-marins nucléaires
lanceurs d'engins ou la composante
aéroportée on l'oublie trop souvent mais
il y a une composante aéroportée qui
permet une certaine forme de diplomatie
coercitive aussi que ne permet pas ne
permet pas la composante marine mais ça
c'est vraiment le le coeur du dispositif
français après il y a un modèle d'armée
complet qui pour dire les choses
légèrement c'est voilà un petit peu de
tout de tout mais en petite quantité
mais qui permet d'avoir un modèle global
cohérent complet donc on a choisi de
réparer ce modèle là exactement et la
phase d'après peut-être plus tard ce
sera de gagner en épaisseur mais faut
aussi voir que lorsqu'il y a opération
il y a intervention en coalition donc
l'idée aussi c'est que les forces
conventionnelles qui viennent à côté de
ce socle nucléaire dont on ne parlera
jamais assez et dont on voit aujourd'hui
qui cadenas la question
Ukraine Russie donc on a raison j'allais
dire de réaffirmer ce modèle dans sa
dans sa vérité et dans son dans le sens
qu'il a voilà mais les forces
conventionnelles convocation à être un
peu épaissie air terre mer cyber et puis
le champ informationnel aussi le
multimilieux multichan ça c'est en
coalition et donc précisément ça a
vocation à s'intégrer notamment dans
l'autonomie stratégique européenne qui
est une une évocation
de ce modèle là et une volonté forte du
président et puis aussi dans un modèle
otanien les deux ne sont pas
incompatibles c'est vraiment
complémentaire avec nos camarades
américains donc précisément intégrer en
ce sens et bien est-ce qu'il y a assez
ou pas de conventionnel il y a assez au
regard de ce que nos contribuables enfin
j'ai contribuables les forces français a
été a été d'accord pour accorder Lucas
Hogan on parle d'économie de guerre en
Russie on l'a souvent dit ça veut dire
quoi concrètement qu'est-ce qui a changé
concrètement ça signifie que en clair
depuis le 24 février 2022 la Russie
étant un état de guerre même si elle ne
le dit pas officiellement toujours pas
donc on est toujours selon le régime
russe en train de mener une opération
militaire spéciale pour autant en fait
depuis automne dernier il y a eu la
mobilisation partielle de la population
il y a eu cette idée qu'effectivement vu
que la Russie est en train était en
train de perdre sur le terrain alors on
m'aidait en Bran de l'économie russe en
fait pour essayer de
d'acheminer
l'effort militaire sur le terrain on
sait que justement j'y revient encore se
plaint régulièrement de ne pas avoir
suffisamment de munitions actuellement
ça travaille en Russie pour que ces
munitions arrivent en néanmoins il faut
bien se rendre compte que si on dit
souvent que les sanctions économiques
n'ont pas d'impact ou moins d'impact ce
qu'on imaginait sur la Russie on sait
aussi que elle a des difficultés à se
procurer certains certains éléments pour
fabriquer justement des obus etc je
pense notamment au semi-conducteur par
exemple
c'est toujours vrai aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'il la met dans une dans une réelle
difficulté néanmoins la réserve d'homme
elle pour le moment reste très
importante effectivement puisque si
effectivement quelques centaines de
milliers d'hommes russes sont partis de
Russie au moment de la mobilisation
partielle on s'est quand même que
l'immense majorité est restée que
l'armée russe au total
fait entre 900 000 et 1 million d'hommes
donc les chiffres évidemment sont à
prendre avec des pincettes mais
aujourd'hui peut-être que l'armée russe
aurait perdue environ 100 000 hommes
depuis le début du conflit ce qui fait
qu'il en resterait quand même évidemment
une part très importante néanmoins c'est
déjà une défaite en soi quand même je
crois qu'on termine avec un chapitre
diplomatique et notamment le rôle de la
de la Chine qui réaffirme c'est l'une
des informations de la journée son
soutien à la Russie le Premier ministre
russe est à Pékin aujourd'hui écoutez-le
aujourd'hui les relations entre la
Russie et la Chine ont atteint un niveau
sans précédent elles sont marquées par
le respect mutuel des intérêts de chacun
l'envie de répondre au défi de manière
conjointe en lien avec l'accroissement
des turbulences sur la scène
internationale et la pression exercée
par des sanctions occidentales
illégitimes et à l'occasion de cette
visite le président chinois a réa attiré
pardon je cite son ferme soutien en
matière d'intérêt fondamentaux Sylvie
Hermann on peut dire rien de nouveau
sous le soleil ça fait ça fait des
semaines qu'on est dans cet état
d'esprit là mais comment la Chine pèse
sur les décisions russes c'est quoi le
mécano entre ces deux pays je pense que
pour le moment la Chine ne pèse pas
véritablement mais
le sol qui pourra être écouté le moment
venu par Vladimir Poutine parce que ils
ont des intérêts communs qui sont liés à
l'ennemi commun que sont les États-Unis
d'ailleurs
ils ont en commun et quand on défend
l'Alliance
atlantique enfin du moins qu'on explique
qu'elle est purement défensive ça ne ça
ne marche pas à Pékin non plus un
dernier mot Lucas Aubin et ce sera la
conclusion de ce débat c'est ces
images-là comment sont-elles utilisées
par le pouvoir russe pour l'objectif du
pouvoir russe il est en interne c'est
assez simple et en externe aussi à
savoir diviser pour mieux régner donc
l'objectif c'est c'est un discours que
Vladimir Poutine tient depuis à peu près
2007 environ et le fameux discours de
Munich en gros il appelle de ses vœux
l'avènement d'un monde multipolaire où
chaque puissance aurait finalement se
partagerait de façon égale la planète
etc alors c'est bien sûr faux mais lui
ça l'arrange énormément étant donné que
la puissance de la Russie est bien moins
importante que la puissance de l'Union
soviétique à l'époque où évidemment
l'URSS et les USA se étaient les
principaux antagonistes de la planète
aujourd'hui lui va dignacoutine il
cherche à montrer en gros qu'il prend le
vent chinois dans les étoile de la
Russie et que du coup étant donné que la
Chine est appelée en tout cas appel
également de ses vœux à devenir l'une
des principales puissances si ce n'est
là principal puissance de la planète de
demain alors si justement la Russie suit
cette direction on aura des jours
heureux en Russie et bien entendu cette
stratégie à des limites puisque
aujourd'hui la Russie m'est concrètement
tous ces œufs dans le même panier d'un
point de vue notamment économique il y a
une rupture avec les puissances
occidentales à l'ouest et il y a cette
idée qu'il faut du coup commercer
principalement avec la Chine sauf que
elle la Chine elle a des intérêts
mondiaux elle ne commerce pas uniquement
avec la Russie et de fait elle a un
avantage stratégique merci beaucoup à
tous je vais rappeler le les titres de
vos livres Sylvie Berman madame
l'ambassadeur s'est aux éditions
talandiers Jérôme claesh la prospective
stratégique qui paraît aujourd'hui aux
éditions Hermann et du casobin
géopolitique de la Russie c'était aux
éditions de La Découverte merci encore
et à bientôt sur public Senn